you or someone you care about has been
diagnosed with prostate cancer this
video will help you understand how
prostate cancer affects your body the
prostate is a gland in men that makes
part of the fluid in semen it's found
just under the bladder
in front of the last
intestine called the rectum the prostate
wraps around part of the urethra which
is the tube that passes urine and semen
out of the body
most prostate cancer starts in tiny sacs
within the gland that make prostatic
fluid here cancer cells form from gland
cells that line the sacs over time
the cancer cells can multiply
and form a malignant or cancerous tumor
however most prostate cancer grows more
slowly than other types of cancer an
important risk for prostate cancer is
age prostate cancer is more common in
men over the age of 65
race is another risk factor prostate
cancer is more common in
african-american men than in any other
race
the risk is also higher in men whose
relatives such as a father or brother
have a history of prostate cancer there
are usually no symptoms and early
prostate cancer however as the tumor
enlarges the prostate you may have the
following symptoms difficulty starting
urination weak interrupted or painful
urination needing to urinate frequently
especially at night
painful ejaculation problems getting an
erection blood in urine or semen
and pain or stiffness in the lower back
hips or pelvis
note that these symptoms may be caused
by prostate enlargement that is not
cancer
if you have prostate cancer your doctor
will need to determine the grade and the
stage or progression of the disease each
grade is based on how normal the
prostate tissue looks under a microscope
the grading system for prostate cancer
is called the Gleason grading system in
the system samples of two main areas of
the tumor will each be given a grade
from one to five the grades will be
added together to give the cancer a
Gleason score between two and ten the
higher the Gleason score the more likely
the cancer is to grow and spread to
other areas each stage for prostate
cancer is based on the amount of cancer
you have and where it's found the stages
are numbered from one to four in stage
one the tumor has not spread outside the
prostate in stage two the cancer is more
advanced but is still only in the
prostate in stage three the cancer has
spread just beyond the outer layer of
the prostate and in stage four the
cancer has spread into nearby tissues
as well as more distant areas of the
body
as you deal with a diagnosis of prostate
cancer continue to talk to your doctor
and you cancer care team